sociétale c'est le secret le moins bien
gardé aux etats-unis à hawaii mais
depuis des semaines
joe biden agit déjà comme un candidat en
campagne
jusqu'à ce week-end à foule ce pays ne
peut plus permettre un président qui
passe son temps à régler ses comptes
lançait-il récemment dans un événement
syndicales pour ravir à dans l'antre up
certains états du midwest plus ultime
ans la maison blanche
joe biden mise sur sa notoriété et son
expérience politique
vice-présidente barack obama pendant
huit ans il a auparavant présenté une
telle away au sénat pendant plus de
trente ans deux heures inos ce sondeur
démocrate décrit un politicien aguerri
qui connaît le fonctionnement du congrès
en plus de bien comprendre les enjeux
mondiaux mais une longue vie publique
est également une arme à double
tranchant
déjà sa gestion dans les années 90 des
audiences d'anita il une femme qui
accusait un candidat à la cour suprême
de harcèlement sexuel lui ont valu des
critiques
puis récemment des femmes ont accusé joe
biden de gestes déplacés des câlins des
baisers qui les ont mises mal à l'aise
sans s'excuser il a affirmé que ce
n'était pas son intention de rendre
quiconque inconfortable qu'il a toujours
voulu réconforter et encourager les gens
qu'il rencontre jo tu t'amuses jo a
lancé dans notre chambre
visiblement satisfait de voir cet
éventuel adversaire critiqué dans son
propre camp joe biden centriste connu
pour collaborer avec les républicains
réussira-t-il à se démarquer face à une
vingtaine de candidats dont certains
prônent un virage à gauche
c'est là tout le défi selon sondeurs
l'ex vice président comme les autres
prétendants encore des mois devant lui
pour présenter sa vision
à 76 ans joe biden tentera sa chance une
troisième fois dans ce qui sera
probablement son ultime campagne pour
devenir président s'il rappelle bouvier
claire avoue canada washington